bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de socrate
on va parler plus particulièrement de la
main
chez socrate je me suis aperçu que
depuis que je fais des vidéos
je n'ai toujours pas aborder ce concept
de maïeutique et on ne peut pas
prétendre animer une chaîne de
philosophie sans se confronter au tard à
ce concept
petit rappel du graphique socrates est
un philosophe de l'antiquité grecque du
5e siècle avant jésus-christ il est
parfois considérée à tort comme le
fondateur de la philosophie occidentale
jeudi à tort parce qu'avant socrates
il y avait ce qu'on appelle les
présocratiques les présocratiques dont
certains non vous seront familiers par
exemple
thales pythagore parménide mais le fait
qu'on les appelle les présocratiques
autrement dit qu'on les définissent par
référence à socrate montre à quel point
socrates a été un personnage extrêmement
important dans l'histoire de la
philosophie occidentale et on va voir
aujourd'hui à quel point il a été ce
crash n'a jamais rien écrit il
professait un enseignement exclusivement
orale et tout ce que l'on connaît de sa
pensée nous a été rapporté par les
textes de ses disciples au premier rang
desquels platon l'auteur des dialogues
socratiques ce qui fait d'ailleurs qu'il
est parfois difficile de différencier ce
qui relève de la pensée de platon ou de
la pensée de socrate
mais toujours est il que la grande
majorité des textes de platon sont des
mises en scène des dialogues de socrate
y socrates a connu une fin tragique
il a été condamné à mort à l'âge de 70
ans par le tribunal d'athènes de quoi
était-il accusent m et biens de trois
chefs d'inculpation impiété introduction
de nouvelles divinités dans la cité et
corruption de la jeunesse donc les deux
premiers chefs d'inculpation concernait
la religion et la corruption de la
jeunesse
je précise tout de suite que ça n'a rien
à voir avec une affaire de moeurs
la corruption de la jeunesse c'était le
fait que à l'époque at elle venait de
subir une lourde défaite militaire
contre sparte et suite à sarm
il s'est agi de trouver des responsables
il se trouve que socrate était vu comme
quelqu'un qui détournait la jeunesse de
son devoir militaire
en l'encourageant à philosopher plutôt
qu à les combattre
si bien que socrate s'est vu reprocher
d'avoir été en partie responsable de
cette défaite
sur la question de l'impiété de
l'introduction de nouvelles divinités
il est vrai que socrate ne cachait pas
sa divergence à l'égard de la religion
traditionnelle d'athènes une religion
polythéiste quand socrates lui parler de
dieu au singulier une religion dont les
divinités était célébrée par le peuple
quand socrates lui parlait de son dimon
c'est à dire de sa divinité personnel le
dimon étant un être divin qui n'est lié
à aucune représentation n'y a aucun
culte
donc pour toutes ces raisons socrates
passer pour un marginal il passait pour
un marginal et sa pratique de la
philosophie lui a valu quelques
inimitiés et lorsqu'il a comparu devant
le tribunal d'athènes il a fait ce qu'il
savait faire de mieux c'est à dire
mettre sa rhétorique au service de la
philosophie pour tenter de démontrer son
innocence
car pour lui le seul crime qu'il avait
commis c'était d'avoir fait de son mieux
pour élever les esprits à la philosophie
mais le fait est que lorsqu'on a proposé
à socrate de définir lui-même sa peine
lorsqu'on lui a dit que s'il choisissait
sa peine ce serait peut-être cette peine
là à laquelle ils seraient condamnés
socrates a pas pu s'empêcher de faire de
la provocation
parce qu'alors il a répondu que sa peine
devrait être d'être nourris au prytanée
le prytanée étant le bâtiment où siègent
les membres du gouvernement c'est un
petit peu l'équivalent du palais de
l'elysée ou de l'assemblée nationale en
france
autrement dit socrates a fait preuve
d'une provocation suprême
c'est à dire qu'alors que peser sur lui
la menace d'une condamnation à mort il
n'a rien trouvé de mieux à dire que ce
qu'il méritait c'était des hommages
nationaux ça n'a pas plu au jury qu'ils
ont donc condamné à mort donc tout ça
est racontée dans le texte de platon qui
s'intitule l'apologie de socrate
et donc socrate à accepter son sort il a
refusé l'aide qui lui était proposé de
s'évader de prison
il a accepté de boire la ciguë
c'est-à-dire de s'empoisonner lui-même
ce qui est une manière digne de faire
ses adieux
d'ailleurs si socrates a laissé son
empreinte dans l'histoire de la
philosophie c'est en grande partie du
fait de cette condamnation à mort
socrates n'est pas simplement un
philosophe c'est aussi une icône un
symbole c'est le symbole de celui qui
est prêt à mourir pour ses idées
socrates et morts pour que vive la
philosophie et d'une certaine manière ce
qu'ils ont condamné à mort ne se sont
pas rendu compte du service qui lui
rendait du service qu'ils rendaient à la
philosophie que socrate honorait mais
vous avez pu constater à travers cette
anecdote socrates s'était d'abord le roi
de la provocation et la provocation
faisait partie intégrante de sa méthode
de son rapport à la philosophie et quand
je parle de provocation
je veux parler de provocation au sens
littéral provoqué quelque chose s'est
créé les conditions pour que cette chose
ait lieu provoqué quelque chose c'est la
faire émerger ces conduire à son
avènement et donc la provocation c'est
peut-être le mot qui résume le mieux la
pratique philosophique de sokratis telle
qu'elle se traduit à travers la
maïeutique alors comme je le disait
socrate n'a jamais écrit aucun livre ce
n'était pas sa manière de faire de la
philosophie écrire des livres lui il
préférait s'exprimer par la conversation
par la discussion par le dialogue
il allait à la rencontre de ses
concitoyens sur l'agora et ils
entamaient la discussion avec eux sur un
sujet ou sur un autre
et à ce moment là il mettait la pensée
en actions
il rendait la pensée vivante à travers
le dialogue
c'est à dire que écrire un livre c'est
exposer une pensée figée une pensée
abouti ou supposément abouti écrire un
livre ses présupposés que ce qui est
écrit est vrai est que le lecteur n'a
plus qu'à lire pour s'instruire
autrement dit il y a dans l'écriture
philosophique quelque chose de
profondément dogmatique et le dogmatisme
pour socrate
c'est précisément l'antithèse de la
philosophie la philosophie ne peut pas
être exposé is you neil elle ne peut pas
être quelque chose qu'on expose et qu'on
n'aurait plus qu'à ingurgité c'est pas
ça la pensée la nature de la pensée
c'est d'être en mouvement c'est d'être
toujours en train de se construire en
train de se créer
la pensée pour socrate c'est un
processus et on a pu en parler dans la
vidéo sur platon et l'allégorie de la
caverne
l'idée c'est de dire qu'on ne passe pas
directement de l'ignorance à la
connaissance on passe par des étapes on
passe par des stades de connaissances et
chaque stade va conduire au stade
suivant
de la même façon que lorsqu'on apprend
les mathématiques
on n'apprend pas directement les
équations du second degré on commence
par apprendre à compter les nombreux
positif et puis ensuite on apprend à
additionner les nombres allait
multiplier à les diviser
et c'est ainsi que d'étapes en étapes on
en arrive aux mathématiques complexes et
abstraite tout apprentissage suppose des
étapes et ses étapes nécessite du temps
elle nécessite de la distance vis-à-vis
de ce qu'on apprend or pour socrate
c'est à travers le dialogue que cette
prise de distance vis-à-vis de la pensée
peut avoir lieu
et donc le dialogue apparaît comme le
meilleur moyen d'accéder à la
connaissance
alors évidemment on va développer cette
idée dans cette vidéo
et j'aimerais déjà que vous reteniez
ceci pour socrate l'exercice de la
pensée est un exercice de la pensée
l'exercice de la pensée ça passe par la
mise en pratique de la pensée
et la mise en pratique de la pensée
c'est la formulation de la pensée c'est
la verbalisation de la pensée autrement
dit la pensée en actions
c'est la pensée qui s'exprime c'est la
pensée en mouvement à travers le
dialogue
pour socrate c'est le dialogue qui
permet l'éclosion de la vérité la vérité
n'est pas remis une liste dénoncé une
liste d'affirmation c'est un processus
par lequel on remplace nos croyances par
des connaissances et pour y arriver
pour remplacer nos croyances par des
connaissances nous avons besoin d'un
interlocuteur nous avons besoin de
quelqu'un qui va réagir à ce que l'on
croît être vrai lorsqu on est tout seul
à penser ce que l'on pense on n'a pas de
retour sur ce que l'on pense ce qui veut
dire qu'on peut très bien tourner en
boucle dans ses propres schémas de
croyance sans jamais en sortir
même avec la meilleure volonté du monde
on a toujours besoin d'une référence
on a toujours besoin d'un point de vue
extérieur le point de vue extérieur
c'est ce qui va nous permettre de faire
un retour sur notre propre pensée c'est
ce qui va nous permettre d'élargir notre
champ de conscience
le jean conscience ne peut s'élargir que
par la prise en compte des points de vue
extérieur
autrement dit par des points de vue qui
ne sont pas le nôtre
il n'y a pas de progrès de la conscience
il n'ya pas d'élévation de la conscience
s'il n'y a pas un moment ou à un autre
prise en compte du point de vue d'autrui
et le fait est que nous ne sommes pas
capables de comprendre le point de vue
d'autrui d'entendre le point de vue
d'autrui si on ne s'y confronte pas si
on n'a pas concrètement à faire à autrui
dans l'expression de notre pensée
quand vous demandez conseil à quelqu'un
on est bien d'accord que ça ne veut pas
dire que vous allez laisser l'autre
pensez à votre place
ça veut simplement dire que vous avez
conscience que vous ne possédez pas
toutes les informations qui a peut-être
un angle de vue qui vous échappe
et c'est normal parce qu'on possède pas
tous les angles de vue aux angles de vue
ils sont le fruit de notre vécu
personnel ils sont le fruit de notre
expérience
ils sont le fruit de mille et un facteur
qui auront façonné notre manière de
penser notre manière de penser
elle est façonnée par notre vécu et
lorsqu'on prend conscience de ça lorsque
l'on comprend qu'on ne possède pas la
science infuse que l'on possède pas
l'omniscience à ce moment là on comprend
le rôle absolument indispensable de
l'autre dans la construction de notre
pensée
ça c'est ce en quoi croyez socrates
l'idée qu'on avait besoin de l'autre
pour s'élever dans la conscience pour
faire progresser notre pensée d'ailleurs
je le précise entre parenthèses il est
de bon ton aujourd'hui de considérer que
chacun possède sa propre vérité
pour socrate comme pour platon ça
n'existe pas on ne possède pas chacun
notre propre vérité parce que par
définition la vérité elle est une et
elle est universelle
donc chacun sa vérité ça n'a pas de sens
c'est à chacun sa vérité c'est chacun sa
conception de la vérité
et ça c'est très différent
c'est très différent parce que ça remet
en place la notion de subjectivité de la
connaissance la subjectivité de la
connaissance ne veut pas dire que la
vérité est personnel ça veut dire que
chacun possède un regard sur la vérité
peut vous savez comme quand vous êtes
sur la route et qu'à un moment donné
vous avez un panneau qui vous indiquent
un point de vue vous pouvez vous arrêter
au bord de la route et profiter d'un
point de vue sur le paysage il à ce
point de vue c'est votre point de vue et
les personnes qui se trouvent de l'autre
côté de la colline que vous êtes en
train de regarder ces personnes ont un
autre point de vue et c'est la synthèse
de tous les points de vue qui d'une
certaine manière constitue la vérité la
vérité elle est trans subjective
elle est la synthèse des subjectivités
elle n'est pas la subjectivité tout seul
la vérité n'est pas notre point de vue
quand vous regardez un d vous ne voyez
pas un d vous voyez tout au plus trois
faces du d
faites l'expérience regardez un des
evaux verrez que vous ne voyez que trois
faces du d alors bien sûr vous savez que
les autres fassent existe et sauf que
vous ne pouvez pas tout les voir en même
temps c'est ça le problème de la
subjectivité
le problème de la subjectivité qui fait
que vous avez besoin d'une autre
subjectivité pour vous répondre
et pour compléter votre propre
subjectivité
alors revenons à socrate et à sa
pratique de la philosophie à travers le
dialogue
pour socrate le rôle du philosophe ce
n'est donc pas de transmettre à son
élève un enseignement un savoir prémâché
un prêt-à-penser parce que ça c'est
contradictoire avec l'esprit même de la
philosophie le rôle du philosophe c'est
de poser les bonnes questions de telle
manière que l'élève accède lui même à la
connaissance la philosophie c'est l'art
d'interroger l'autre de manière à faire
émerger en lui la connaissance ce n'est
pas à d'exposer une vérité tout fait en
laquelle il faudrait avoir confiance une
confiance aveugle
une confiance uniquement basée sur
l'autorité d'ailleurs la distinction
entre maîtres et disciples repose
précisément sur cette notion d'autorité
le mettre ma guise terre qui a donné
cours magistral
c'est celui qui possèderait une autorité
qui en ferait quelqu'un de digne de
confiance
le m on écoute et on le croit
pourquoi est-ce qu'on le croit parce que
c'est le maître parce que son statut lui
confère une autorité et qu'on serait
finalement obligé de croire sur parole
alors je ne dis pas qu'il faut toujours
chercher à contredire ce que dit m c'est
pas ça mais c'est simplement que l'idée
selon laquelle il faudrait croire tout
ce que dit le maître parce qu'il est le
maître c'est le contraire même de
l'esprit de la connaissance
parce que la connaissance c'est d'abord
un mouvement interne
c'est un élan intérieur
je prendrai un exemple qu'est ce qui
pousse l'enfant a posé des questions à
ses parents à les assauts m question
sans arrêt c'est pas parce que son
maître à l'école lui a demandé de le
faire mais c'est parce qu'il est poussé
par une force intérieure qui s'appelle
la curiosité et la curiosité c'est une
impulsion vers la connaissance
c'est quelque chose qui se trouve à
l'intérieur de nous et qui est comme une
sorte de désir de conquête du monde par
l'esprit la curiosité c'est le désir de
conquérir le monde par l'esprit donc
c'est une déclinaison du désir
on a vu que pascal se reprocher beaucoup
sa curiosité parce qu'il était conscient
que sa curiosité n'était rien d'autre
que le vêtement de son désir et le fait
est qu'un enfant n'apprend jamais aussi
bien que lorsqu'il est curieux la
curiosité donne envie d'apprendre et
avoir envie d'apprendre
c'est le meilleur moyen d'apprendre on
n'est jamais aussi efficace dans
l'apprentissage
on n'est jamais aussi bons élèves que
quand on al'envie d'apprendre lorsqu'on
aime ce qu'on étudie l'étudier n'est
plus une contrainte ça devient un
plaisir et ce plaisir c'est la
traduction de la satisfaction notre
intérêt et mais quelque chose c'est le
meilleur moyen de s'y intéresser
donc tout ça pour dire que la relation
hiérarchique entre le maître et le
disciple socrates la récuse socrates la
considère comme étant une imposture
parce que précisément ce schéma-là
présuppose que la connaissance peut être
apportée de l'extérieur et qu'à ce
moment là
celui qui apprend n'est qu'un réceptacle
passif n'est qu'un spectateur dans
l'apprentissage suppose une démarche
active
l'élève doit être actif socrates n'est
pas quelqu'un qu'on écoute et dont on
reçoit la vérité socrates est celui qui
participe à l'émergence de la vérité en
nous
parce que si on se place dans ce schéma
d'autorité c'est à dire qu'on accepte de
recevoir l'enseignement de quelqu'un
considéré comme étant l'autorité mais ça
veut dire qu'on n'est pas dans la
connaissance
on est dans la croyance puisque la
croyance c'est précisément le fait
d'accepter une information comme étant
vrai sans l'avoir vérifié par soi même
alors il ya des tas de choses pour
lesquelles on fait ça aucun d'entre nous
n'a jamais vérifié à titre personnel que
la terre est ronde
mais pourtant nous sommes grande
majorité à le penser
nous sommes grande majorité à le croire
à le croire parce que on ne peut pas
faire mieux que de le croire on peut pas
le vérifier par nous-mêmes en tout cas
du point de vue de l'observation
ça paraît difficile donc on le croit
parce qu'on a confiance dans ce qu'ils
nous ont transmis cette information
comme étant vrai et qu'à un moment donné
on est obligé de faire confiance à une
autorité mais ne fêtait que au quotidien
nous admettons des choses comme vrai
sans les avoir vérifiées par nous mêmes
on le fait tous mais quand on fait ça on
est dans la croyance
on n'est pas dans la connaissance parce
que la connaissance c'est le processus
intérieur de reconnaissance de la vérité
ce n'est pas l'enregistrement passif et
aveugle de ce que nous dit le maître
c'est tout le contraire
eh bien c'est exactement ça la
maïeutique la maïeutique c'est l'art de
faire émerger la connaissance par le
questionnement
c'est l'art de faire accéder notre
interlocuteur à la connaissance en lui
donnant l'occasion de répondre lui même
à ces interrogations
c'est ça la maïeutique l'art de faire
émerger la connaissance dans la
conscience de l'autre
alors petite mise au point
terminologique le mot maïeutique il
vient du nom de la déesse maya qui
veillait aux accouchements et je trouve
que les textes rapporte que la mère de
socrates était elle-même sage femme
autrement dit elles pratiquaient la
maïeutique dans son sens étymologique
c'est à dire celui de faire accoucher
d'ailleurs il se trouve que le masculin
pour sage femme c'est maïeuticien il n'y
a pas de sage homme il ya des maillots
titien et le choix de ce mot maïeutique
il est typique de cette habitude de
socrate de recourir à des analogies ici
c'est l'analogie entre le corps et
l'esprit
la mère de socrate faisait à coucher les
corps socrates lui fait accoucher les
esprits et de coiffes et ont accouché
les esprits des idées l'esprit c'est le
ventre des idées or vous aurez remarqué
que si on suit cette analogie la sage
femme lorsqu'elle fait accoucher la mère
de son enfant elle l'a fait accoucher de
quelque chose qui est en elle
l'enfant est dans le ventre de la mère
ce n'est pas la sage-femme qui crée
l'enfant ce n'est pas la sage femme qui
donne l'enfant la sage femme
elle permet à l'enfant de sortir du
ventre de sa mère est bien la même façon
le philosophe c'est celui qui permet aux
idées de sortir de l'esprit humain
le philosophe c'est un accoucheur des
esprits et là il ya quelque chose de
très intéressant à noter c'est que par
le dialogue
qu'est ce que nous faisons nous
échangeons des idées nous les exprimons
les verbalisons autrement dit nous les
extériorise ont exprimé
ça veut dire littéralement poussé à
l'extérieur où c'est en dehors quand on
exprime une émotion
ça veut dire qu'on la laisse être perçue
par l'autre exprimait ses poussées en
dehors et donc exprimer une idée c'est
la faire sortir de nous sait la mettre à
distance de nous-mêmes pour pouvoir la
contempler pour pouvoir l'observer
l'analyser et la juger lorsqu on exprime
une idée on la tient à distance de nous
mêmes et donc on est capable d'avoir un
recul critique sur cette idée un recul
critique qu'on n'aurait pas eu si cette
idée était resté dans notre esprit une
distance critique qui nous aurait été
impossible d'avoir si cette idée était
resté dans la mélasse de nos pensées
intérieures
parce que lorsque nos pensées sont à
l'intérieur de notre esprit elle s'y
trouve très bien c'est très confortable
pour les idées d'être à l'intérieur de
l'esprit mais en étant à l'intérieur de
l'esprit elles ne sont pas poussés à la
remise en cause critiques elles ne sont
pas poussés à l'évaluation critique de
la même façon que l'enfant n'a aucune
envie de sortir du ventre de sa mère
pour affronter le monde
il est très bien dans le ventre de sa
mère il est au chaud il est nourri il
est à l'abri du monde mais en étant à
l'abri du monde il ne va pas pouvoir
évoluer
il ne peut pas grandir il ne peut pas
croître se développer et accéder à la
maturité
si l'enfant ne sort pas du ventre de sa
mère il est voué à ne jamais s'accomplir
de la même façon une idée qui reste dans
le cocon de notre esprit une idée qui
refuse de se confronter au monde
c'est une idée qui est condamné à ne
jamais devenir vrai
rester qu'une croyance et d'ailleurs
vous remarquerez comme parfois il suffit
de prononcer une idée il suffit
d'exprimer verbalement une pensée pour
la voir autrement pour la considérer
sous un autre angle justement sous un
autre angle de vue c'est normal parce
qu'en exprimant une idée on la sort de
nous mêmes on en fait un objet de pensée
et c'est ce qui fait que parfois nos
prises de conscience pas simplement par
la verbalisation
on va dire quelque chose qui était au
fond nous qu'on n'avait jamais prononcé
et il suffit de le prononcer pour tout à
coup mieux comprendre c'est ce qui fait
d'ailleurs que les thérapie
psychanalytique passe par ce recours au
langage ce recours à la verbalisation
pour mettre à distance de nous mêmes ce
qui est enfoui à l'intérieur de nous et
c'est ce qui fait que parfois il suffit
d'écouter l'autre pour résoudre ces
problèmes parce qu'on écoute en l'autre
on lui donne l'occasion de s'entendre
lui-même la maïeutique caylar d'expulser
à l'extérieur de notre esprit ce qui est
au fond de notre esprit mais dont nous
n'avons pas conscience et par ce
processus nous prenons conscience de ce
que nous pensons et alors il nous
devient possible de corriger ce que nous
pensons voir ce qui n'est pas cohérent
de voir ce qui n'est pas conforme à la
vérité de voir ce qui se contredit et
donc ça ça ne passe pas par la
transmission extérieure d'un savoir que
l'on accepte au nom d'une autorité
ça passe par la provocation d'un
mouvement intérieur vers l'extérieur
autrement dit un mouvement qui a besoin
de nous pour avoir lieu la maïeutique
elle a besoin de nous pour avoir lieu
et ainsi lorsque les questions sont bien
formulé lorsqu'elles visent juste et
qu'il suffit pour l'interlocuteur de
consulter sa raison puisque les grecs
appelé le logos bien à ce moment là la
réponse devient une évidence lorsque les
questions sont bien posées
paradoxalement il n'y a plus besoin de
réfléchir
la vérité elle sort d'elle même elles
sortent elles mêmes à condition qu'on
joue le jeu de la vérité
à condition qu'on soit dans une démarche
de bonne foi de sincérité intellectuelle
c'est sûr que si vous pratiquez la
maïeutique avec quelqu'un qui a décidé
que de toute façon il ne changerait pas
d'avis que de toute façon il avait
raison ça sert à rien on n'obtiendrait
rien tout ce que vous obtiendrez c'est
de l'esprit de contradiction
c'est de la mauvaise foi c'est du repli
sur les croyances parce qu'il ne faut
pas oublier que nos croyances nous y
sommes attachés
nous en avons besoin parce que notre
équilibre identitaire en dépend
certaines croyances sont indispensables
à la conception que nous avons nous
mêmes et si ces croyances s'effondre
c'est une partie nous mêmes qui
s'effondre c'est peut-être même toute
notre vie qui s'effondre et nous ne
voyons pas toujours qu'il faut parfois
que certaines choses s'effondrent pour
pouvoir les reconstruire une croyance
qui s'effondre c'est la fin d'un monde
c'est la fin de notre monde c'est une
mort parce que l'effondrement d'une
croyance nous rappelle que nous avons eu
tort et que donc nous avons vécu dans
l'erreur
et savoir que l'on a vécu dans l'erreur
surtout si on a beaucoup misé sur cette
erreur surtout si on a beaucoup investi
dans cette erreur c'est très difficile à
supporter même devenir totalement
insoutenable donc il faut être disposé à
accepter le jeu de la maïeutique
c'est-à-dire à accepter le jeu de la
cohérence avec soi même si on commence à
vouloir négocier avec la raison si on
commence à vouloir trouver des chemins
détournés pour arriver à la conclusion
qu'on s'était fixé en amont il certain
que la maïeutique n'aura aucune
efficacité
ce sera une perte de temps mais si votre
but c'est d'accéder à la vérité c'est de
faire progresser votre connaissance
parce que la connaissance c'est votre
meilleur allié connaissance c'est
toujours quelque chose de plus et jamais
quelque chose de moins bien à ce
moment-là vous entrez dans l'arène
philosophique de la confrontation à la
raison si la maïeutique et efficace
c'est pour deux raisons la première
raison c'est que tout être humain
possède en lui ce que j'ai appelé tout à
l'heure le logos c'est à dire la raison
la raison c'est une faculté humaine
universelle qui va se développer de
manière diverse selon les personnes mais
nous en sommes tous dotés le gosse c'est
l'outil que nous avons reçu de la nature
pour accéder à la connaissance et le
logos c'est quelque chose de très simple
ça repose sur le principe de non
contradiction à savoir quelque chose ne
peut pas à la fois être et ne pas être
ce qu'elle est alors évidemment il ya
toujours des situations intermédiaires
des situations de mélange et d'une
manière générale on comprend ce que ça
veut dire qu'on prend par exemple qu'il
ne peut pas à la fois faire jour et
faire nuit à la fois monté les escaliers
et les descendre c'est pas compatible
c'est notre faculté logique qui nous
permet de le comprendre et vous n'avez
pas besoin de faire appel à des
connaissances extérieur pour vous rendre
compte de cette évidence logique cette
évidence elle vous saute à l'esprit donc
face à une question
une question fermée une question binaire
la logique est en mesure de nous donner
la réponse est donc le rôle du
maïeuticien le rôle du philosophe qui
s'inspire de la méthode socratique ça va
être de trouver les questions auxquelles
la bonne réponse s'impose comme une
évidence
et au fur et à mesure du questionnement
le rôle du philosophe ça va être de
resserrer ces questions de manière à
arriver à une conclusion
et cette conclusion parce qu'elle aura
subi la série d épreuves logique la
série d épreuves face aux logos elle
sera nécessairement la vérité parce que
du vrai ne peut naître que le vrai et
parce que d'une série de propositions
correctes ne peut jaillir qu'une
conclusion correct
c'est ça l'idée de la maïeutique et ça
rejoint encore une fois l'idée du
sentiment d'évidence le sentiment
d'évidence qui naît de la confrontation
à quelque chose de totalement logique
quand vous êtes confrontés à quelque
chose de logique il y à cette lumière
qui s'allume dans votre esprit et qui
vous dit évidemment c'est ça le
sentiment d'évidence l'idée que ça ne
peut être que ça et donc c'est très
intéressant parce que ça permet de
définir la notion de connaissance du
point de vue de socrate à savoir que la
connaissance ce n'est pas une
construction
ce n'est pas une production une création
d'idées la connaissance c'est une
reconnaissance
autrement dit la connaissance est un
dévoilement
qu'est ce que ça veut dire elle ça veut
dire que connaître ce n'est pas créer
quelque chose qui est vraie connaître
s'est levé le voile sur quelque chose
qui est vraie la connaissance est un
dévoilement
c'est à dire littéralement le retrait du
voile autrement dit la vérité elle est
toujours là on a construit pas on ne les
invente pas elle est là et notre travail
c'est d'enlever ce qui la voile c'est
d'enlever ce qui la couvre de la
découvrir
c'est de la révéler or il se trouve
qu'en grec le mot vérité se disait
aletheia qui signifiait littéralement
retrait du voile la vérité c'est le
retrait du voile des apparences le
retrait du voile de la confusion
le retrait du voile des croyances qui
nous empêche de faire face à la vérité
et attention ne pas vouloir regarder la
vérité en face ne pas vouloir ôter les
croyances qui la couvre c'est quelque
chose qu'on fait tous le phénomène du
déni c'est pas quelque chose que l'on
fait avec plaisir c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on fait parce qu'on l'a décidé
le matin en se levant et les tas de
personnes qui sont dans le déni
permanent parce qu'il en va de leur
sécurité psychique et il en va de notre
sécurité psychique à tous de vouloir
fermer les yeux sur certaines choses
parce qu'elle nous insécurise
psychiquement
les personnes qui ont vécu des
traumatismes d'une violence épouvantable
et qui ont besoin de recouvrir ce
traumatisme par des croyances par une
image qu'elle se seront construites
d'elle-même par la réécriture d'un
scénario qui aura donné à leur histoire
un autre sens et une autre direction
c'est tout à fait normal
la philosophie ne prétend pas
bouleverser les lois psychique
certainement pas la philosophie prétend
apporter à ceux qui sont dans une
démarche consciente de recherche de la
vérité à pouvoir disposer d'un outil qui
le leur permet et donc je reprend là où
je m'étais arrêté je disais que le
sentiment d'évidence
c'est quelque chose qui prend la forme
d'une reconnaissance et je vous invite
vraiment à faire l'expérience par vous
même quand vous êtes face à une
démonstration logique dont la conclusion
vous apparaît évidente
observez ce qui se passe en vous à ce
moment-là observer la nature de votre
réaction
et vous allez voir que la nature de
votre réaction c'est vous dire mme que
ce que vous avez sous les yeux
c'est comme si vous l'aviez toujours su
comme si ça avait toujours été là et que
ce n'était qu'à ce moment là que vous le
découvriez mais ça a toujours été là
cette évidence elle n'est pas née au
moment où vous en êtes rendu compte
votre prise de conscience ne correspond
pas à la naissance de cette vérité cette
vérité a toujours été là et vous ne
faites que la reconnaître et ça c'est la
deuxième raison pour laquelle la
maïeutique apparaît pour socrate comme
la meilleure méthode d'investigation du
vrai pour le comprendre il va falloir
mettre un petit peu de côté nos
conceptions modernes et accepté de se
glisser dans l'esprit d'un grec de
l'antiquité c'est à dire de quelqu'un
qui pouvait éventuellement croire dans
l'existence des vies antérieures
quand on a une certaine conception de ce
qu'est l'âme l'hypothèse de la
réincarnation devient quelque chose de
totalement envisageable si la mais bien
une entité immatériel qui a une
existence autonome par rapport au corps
qu'à ce moment là il est très facile de
concevoir ce que platon appelle la
migration de l'âme c'est à dire que lahm
va prendre possession d'un autre corps
lorsque le corps précédent sera rivée à
son échéance
donc là on rentre dans le socrate
mystique et donc cette théorie selon
laquelle l'âme migrent de corps en corps
de manière éternelle
c'est ce que platon appelé la
réminiscence la réminiscence
c'est l'idée que à chaque nouvelle
incarnation l'âme oublie tout ce qu'elle
savait elle oublie toutes les
connaissances accumulées au fur et à
mesure de ses expériences au fur et à
mesure de ses existence antérieure
autrement dit nous naissons tous
amnésiques
nous sommes tous amnésiques des
expériences de notre âme et donc notre
existence terrestre va nous permettre de
nous re souvenir c'est à dire de nous
souvenir de ce que nous savions déjà de
ce que notre âme savait déjà c'est un
peu ça l'idée c'est que nous avons
besoin d'oublier pour pouvoir nous
souvenir et à ce moment là
nouvelles connaissances va réactiver à
l'intérieur de notre âme
l'ancien connaissances dont la nouvelle
n'est qu'une confirmation dont la
nouvelle n'est qu'une reconnaissance
reconnaître quelque chose comme vrai ça
signifie l'avoir déjà connus comme vrai
et donc l'expérience de l'évidence
l'expérience de la reconnaissance de
quelque chose comme étant vrai de toute
éternité
cette expérience là nous dit socrates
elle est liée au fait que notre âme
savait déjà parce que notre âme
elle a déjà contempler les essences
intelligible elle a déjà contempler les
idées elle a déjà contempler la vérité
et c'est là que la célèbre citation de
socrate connais toi toi même prend tout
son sens connais toi toi même autrement
dit regarde à l'intérieur de toi observe
à l'intérieur de toi et tu verras au
fond de toi tu sais la vérité est déjà à
l'intérieur de toi tu n'as pas la craie
et tu n'as pas la construire
elle est là sous tes yeux tu n'as qu'à
les ouvrir c'est ça l'idée de la
réminiscence
nous connaissons tous la vérité nous
l'avons tous à l'intérieur de notre âme
parce que notre âme l'a déjà vu et donc
la connaissance ce n'est rien d'autre
que le processus par lequel l'homme se
souvient de ce qu'elle a toujours su et
là vous comprenez que ça donne un tout
autre sens à ce qu'on appelait tout à
l'heure la reconnaissance c'est l'âme
qui reconnaît la vérité qu'elle avait
déjà vu et qui fait dire à socrate que
la vérité est effectivement en nous elle
est toujours en nous mais simplement
nous l'avons oublié et la maïeutique
c'est ce qui permet de réactiver cette
connaissance endormi le dialogue permet
le réveil de nos vérités endormi
donc la voyez qu'on est sur un terrain
un petit peu particulier le terrain de
la mystique mais ça fait partie
intégrante de la pensée de socrate et je
me devais de vous expliciter cette
conception de l'âme humaine qui fait de
la connaissance
un processus de reconnaissance alors il
se trouve que la méthode de la
maïeutique ce couple à un second
principe qu'on a déjà pu voir dans la
vidéo sur hegel c'est le principe de la
dialectique ont très rapidement
dialectique ça vient du grec d'y aller
games qui est issu du mot dialogue et
dialogues littéralement dialogos c'est
le logos qui se divise en deux c'est la
raison partager le dialogue
c'est le lieu de déploiement de la
raison sous une forme divisée c'est une
manière intéressant de concevoir ce
qu'est le dialogue parce que ça permet
de comprendre que c'est à 2 qu'on accède
à la vérité autrement dit l'accès à la
vérité suppose toujours un détachement
vis-à-vis de soi-même et la dialectique
c'est le principe selon lequel on accède
à la connaissance par le jeu des
contradictions c'est par élimination du
faut que l'on se rapproche du vrai on
n'accède pas à la vérité d'emblée on
n'accepte pas la vérité par un saut on
doit en passer par la réfutation la
contradiction et c'est à force d'avoir
surmonté toutes les contradictions que
l'on accède à quelque chose qui mérite
le nom de vérité et ça c'est quelque
chose dont on fait tous l'expérience au
quotidien c'est à dire qu'on fait des
erreurs qu'on essaye tant bien que mal
d'apprendre de ses erreurs pour ne pas
les reproduire
c'est le principe même de
l'apprentissage que de se baser sur nos
expériences passées pour ne pas
reproduire les mêmes erreurs
ce qui veut dire que les erreurs nous
aident à condition qu'on y soit attentif
à condition qu'on les corrige
c'est à dire à condition qu'on change ce
qui est à l'origine de nos anciennes
erreurs parce que prendre conscience
d'une erreur pour la répéter
indéfiniment
c'est pas très utile
c'est pas ça qui va nous faire
progresser mais faire des erreurs en
étant attentif au pourquoi de nos
erreurs et à ce moment là on progresse
dans la connaissance
l'idée maîtresse de la dialectique c'est
que la contradiction est le moteur de la
connaissance
la contradiction est le moteur de la
ce qui veut dire que si on accepte
l'idée de la remise en question de soi
si on accepte et qu'on assume nos
erreurs pour justement ne plus avoir à
les reproduire
et bien ce moment là nos erreurs nous
ont été utiles aux serrures nous auront
été bénéfiques et on pourrait presque
remercier nos erreurs pour nous avoir
guidé sur le bon chemin
c'est à force d'emprunter le mauvais
chemin que l'on finit par se réorienter
sur le bon chemin et c'est là que le
rôle d'autrui va être absolument
fondamental parce que l'autre va être
l'occasion de la contradiction est une
contradiction c'est toujours désagréable
précisément parce que ça heurte nos
croyances et que nous sommes attachés à
nos croyances
on a pas que nos croyances soient
bousculés mais sauf qu en étant bousculé
nos idées vont réagir
elles vont réagir en se remettant en
ordre elles vont tenir compte de la
contradiction qu'elles auront subi pour
ne plus avoir à la subir et tenir compte
de la contradiction
ça ne veut pas dire dresser un bouclier
devant nos idées ça veut pas dire
devenir agressif envers ceux qui vont
contredire nos idées
ça veut dire faire évoluer nos idées de
telle façon qu'elle ne soit plus soumise
à la contradiction
c'est un processus d'adaptation de même
façon que lorsque vous fait subir à vos
muscles un stress vos muscles vont
s'adapter
le muscle s'adapte parce qu'il n'a pas
d'autre choix que de s'adapter
il est obligé de prendre en compte la
pression qu'il a reçus pour ne plus
avoir à subir et en prenant en compte ce
qu'il aura subis le muscle va se
développer va se renforcer de telle
sorte qu'il ne sera plus vulnérable au
prochain choc l'esprit fonctionne
exactement de la même manière et c'est
pour ça que en l'absence d'interlocuteur
avec qui exerçait la maïeutique il peut
devenir utile de pratiquer la maïeutique
avec soi même
autrement dit de penser contre soi on
sait contre soi c'est être soi même
notre propre contradicteurs notre propre
opposants pour mettre à l'épreuve nos
croyances et voir si elle supporte le
poids de la contradiction on sait contre
soi c'est accepter que tout ce que l'on
sait c'est ce que l'on croit savoir et
que nul n'est à l'abri de la remise en
cause y être dans l'erreur n'a jamais
été un problème
le problème est d'en sortir et on peut
en sortir en à condition d'admettre que
l'on a été le vrai ça
je n'ai pas celui qui sait dressage et
celui qui sait qu'il ne sait pas croire
que l'on sait prétendre que l'on sait
c'est se condamner à errer dans les
couloirs obscurs de la certitude sans
jamais pouvoir trouver l'issue c'est se
convaincre que l'on est sur le bon
chemin
tout en sachant au fond de soi que ce
n'est pas la bonne route
savoir que l'on ne sait pas c'est savoir
que l'on a encore tout à apprendre et
tout ce que je sais n'est là que pour
être piétinée que pour être renversée et
fertiliser ce qui sera ma connaissance
de demain tous les jours une partie de
nos croyances s'effondre nous savons
mais nous ne voulons pas nous
n'acceptons pas nous n'acceptons pas de
laisser mourir nos croyances
nous tenons elle nous y sommes habitués
quelque part nous les aimons nous les
aimons pas
ce qu'elle nous permette de nous définir
nous les aimons parce que nous nous
identifions elle nous avons l'impression
que si nous les perdons nous ne sommes
plus rien sommes livrés aux ténèbres de
l'inconnu mais l'inconnue n'est rien
d'autre que ceux qui demandent à être
connu l'inconnue n'est rien d'autre que
l'autre côté du connu l'autre côté du
des étroits phase que nous ne voyons pas
nous sommes effrayés par l'autre côté
nous sommes effrayés par ce qui est
derrière l'horizon sans voir que
l'horizon recul à mesure que nous
avançons s'élever à la connaissance à la
connaissance de soi à la connaissance du
monde c'est accepter de mourir c'est
accepter la mort de nos croyances la
mort une partie de nous-mêmes et savoir
que de sept morts nous remettrons nous
remettrons toujours je vous remercie
[Musique]